Hello. Guess what? It's pastry week.
Are you excited for pastry week,
Noel?
I am. Prue's made us all these
fabulous pastries
to get us in the mood.
Try one of these. They're
delish delosh. I certainly will.
Don't eat me. I'm nice.
Did you hear something? No. Oh!
Murderer.
Welcome... to
The Great British Bake Off.
Last time... Ready, steady...
..the bakers faced chocolate week...
They're a bit raw.
..and collectively ballsed up the
basics.
This looks like they've been
dropped. Yeah.
They fought back with stunning
celebration cakes...
The overall appearance, I think, is
spectacular.
..but Lottie still found herself in
the firing line.
It's overbaked. Although in the end
it was Sura.. You have raw dough.
..who bit the bullet.
Now, midway through the
competition...
Halfway to paradise.
..the bakers face the perils of
pastry week.
It's bonkers.
Taking on some of the most intricate
challenges...
There's so many steps in this.
..ever set. This is definitely the
hardest so far.
Making architecture edible,
but the wrong kind of flaky...
Just really baffled.
This is a joke... can see the best
of plans...
This is what this entire bake hinges
on.
This is horrendous.
..come crashing down.
It's pastry week!
This is the week that I wanted to
get to because I know that I can
make pastry.
You know, lots of us mums can make
pastry.
I can finally say that I am looking
forward to pastry week.
It is my week!
Halfway has suddenly crept up on us,
hasn't it?
It feels bizarre that we're already
at this point, yeah.
We're so far through, um, exciting
though.
I do like making pastry, but I
have to say this is definitely
one of the weeks where a lot could
go wrong.
Nobody wants a soggy bottom.
Got a crisp bottom.
I feel apprehensive, actually, about
pastry.
The judges are saying they want to
see a bit more refinement from me.
So, I want to show them that I can
do elegant. Yeah.
Good morning, bakers. Welcome back
to the tent
for pastry week.
And it's time for your
Signature Challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue would like you
each to make your version
of the Cornish national dish -
the pasty.
You need to make eight identical
pasties.
You can use any pastry or filling
you choose,
but feel free to personalise them
with a decorative finish.
They need to be at least 15cm long,
but they can be any shape you like.
Noel, what shape would yours be?
Mine would be in the shape of Paul
Hollywood's powerful buttocks.
Mmm, delish delosh.
You have two hours. On your marks..
Get set... bake!
Hello, hello, pasties.
Puff pastry will make a good pasty.
Nice and buttery.
Packed with filling.
Why did they have to say it's the
Cornish national dish?
Just to give me more pressure?
It's pastry week. Most of our
challenges are pure baking
challenges.
This time, the bakers have to be
good cooks too
because what's going inside the
pasty takes real cooking.
The trick is choosing your pastry
and your filling wisely.
You don't want it to be too dry.
As you bite into the pasty, the
buttery layer from the shell must be
nice and thin, crispy.
And then inside, as you hit that
filling, you want a bit of moisture
in there as well.
It doesn't have to be a Cornish
pasty shape,
it can be any shape they like, but
we want crimping.
Halfway through now, and I expect
the bakers really to start
pushing themselves
and coming up with some ingenious
ways to really impress the judges.
I want to eat the best pasties I've
ever had.
Hello, Laura. Morning. Hello, Laura.
Making a mess again, I see. Yep.
Tell us about your pasty.
So, I'm going quite traditional.
I'm doing a cheese and onion pasty.
Paul just said to me, not 30 seconds
ago, that he likes a cheese and onion
pasty. Oh, really?
Laura's pimping her traditional
cheese and onion filling
with leeks, cream and fresh thyme,
and she's aiming to impress with her
choice of pastry too.
I'm doing a cheats puff pastry
learnt from a book from a very
famous baker called Paul Hollywood.
I think you'll do well on this
challenge. You reckon?
Well, if it all falls to bits, it's
his fault, isn't it? Yeah.
I'm not taking the blame. Good luck,
Laura.
Thank you, thanks. Thank you.
I just can't mess it up.
But she's not the only baker taking
a risk making rough puff.
Flaky pastry. It doesn't matter how
you get there, right?
Lottie, Peter and Linda are all
using it to reimagine the
traditional pasty.
You're meant to see streaks of
butter in your pastry.
I'm doing an envelope fold. An
envelope fold, letter fold.
I don't know.
Whilst rivals Marc, Mark, and Dave
are making a sturdy short crust.
You could overwork it. You don't
want it to turn tough.
But Hermine is creating a pastry
that is entirely her own.
It's not quite a puff pastry, but
it's not a short pastry either.
I kind of wanted best of both
worlds.
Hermine's hybrid pastry will be
packed with a
tangy Moroccan
spiced lamb tagine
and chickpea filling.
I think it sounds absolutely
delicious. As long as the pastry
doesn't fall to bits.
Thank you.
How much chilli have I got?
I haven't got too much.
Planning to pack a punch with his
pasties is Mark.
So, I am doing aloo gobi and paneer
pasties, which will be spiced with
lots of turmeric, cumin,
coriander, lots of ginger and
garlic.
So, a lot going on in this.
Mark's Indian inspired cauliflower
and paneer pasties
will even come with spiced pastry,
as he tries to CURRY favour with
Paul and Prue again.
Last week - Star Baker. How do you
feel today?
It feels great coming into this
week, but definitely the nerves
don't go away.
That's the sad thing. Star Baker
doesn't guarantee anything.
No. Look at them trying to take it
away from you already. I know,
already, yeah.
You know you have to prove yourself
every time.
Exactly, yeah. Absolutely.
Really, really grateful for the
smell of fish this early in the
morning. Is that you?
That's going crazy.
Getting the pasty fillings right...
Oh, that's gorgeous.
..is just as crucial as producing
flawless pastry...
You can never have too much cheese.
A bit more?
Just work it all in.
..incredible flavours..
Not sure I can fit any more spices
in these.
..must be complimented with a
perfectly balanced texture.
I'm happy with that.
I am making toad in the hole
pasties.
I'm actually calling it
toad-in-the-hole-less pasty
cos I wasn't really sure what was
the toad and what was the hole.
Lottie's take on this old favourite
will see mashed potato,
onion, sage and fennel gravy, and
Lincolnshire sausage
packed into her pasty.
Oh, Lottie. I am not totally
convinced by this.
One, I think it could be
really stodgy
or soggy - mash and gravy and...
I think it sounds delicious.
It does, yeah.
Lottie... Love toad-in-the-hole.
..you're always original. Thank you.
I'll take that. I have hope, if not
faith.
Thanks, Prue, that's all I need.
Do you know what? I'm going to take
that with me - home probably - but
still I am going to take it.
Bakers, weirdly we are already
halfway through.
Wow! Where does the time go?
Into a small bum bag that
Paul Hollywood wears.
That's where time goes, kids.
I'm just worried about time now, to
be honest. It really is
disappearing.
I think this is my third turn.
Can't go too many.
More turns, more lamination.
If making perfect pastry isn't time
consuming enough,
Pete is planning on sculpting a
whole school of fish pasties.
I'm saying these pasties are in the
shape of a haddock cos I've got
smoked haddock in it.
But it's more shaped like
just generic fish.
His carefully crafted
pasties will be filled with
the haddock and kedgeree rice
and have a boiled egg centre.
And come complete with puff pastry
scales.
Do you even slightly think about
getting to the final? Yeah.
You want to do the best you can.
So much. It's burning you up inside.
It's why I love you because you're
really competitive.
I'd be like that.
Peter's not the only baker hoping to
secure victory by giving pasties a
whole new look.
They're going to be in the shape of
a samosa.
We've been to Goa a couple of times.
I used to walk quite a way
in the morning
just to get these samosas that were
absolutely beautiful.
Linda's Goan inspired pasties will
be filled with spiced chicken,
coriander and potato,
with a design flourish that is not
leaving anything to fate.
I'm going to attempt to put a little
karma symbol...
Oh, OK, nice ..in Nigella seeds.
Also, I am hoping that it does stay
there.
If you don't mark this highly, it's
gonna come back at you. Yeah.
Dave's also taking inspiration from
his travels.
My filling's based on a meal that I
had out in Thailand.
So, this is a Thai chilli basil
chicken pasty.
Dave's chicken and jasmine
rice filling
will come with a sweet
chilli dipping sauce on the side.
And his pasties will be decorated
with chilli motifs.
They're not too hot. They're bird's
eye chillies.
It gives the pasty a kick rather
than an over-powering chilli taste.
So, now I am on to rolling out my
pastry and cutting out the shapes
for my pasties.
Hopefully that's rested.
With 45 minutes of the bake left...
I'm not being too precise about it.
..the bakers must carefully manage
every remaining second.
I want to get them nice and thin,
but taking me absolute ages to get
these right.
The more time spent on building
their pasties...
I've got to make sure the filling is
completely cold before I add it
into the pastry,
else it's just going to melt
the pastry completely.
..the less time they'll get in the
oven.
A fairly generous amount of filling
goes in there.
That is quite tasty, actually,
I must admit.
I've got to be mindful not to put
too much on,
which is what I normally do,
and then struggle to crimp it.
Having set up home in the
south-west,
Marc's got a lot riding on his
reinterpretation of the iconic pasty.
You are from Cornwall, aren't you? I
know. No pressure there, is there?
Technically, though, I'm from up
north. So, that's my get-out clause
if they go wrong.
No, you are representing Cornwall.
You won't be able to go back.
No, they won't let me back in.
Marc's paying homage to the Cornish
coast with a monkfish, samphire
creamy lemon sauce filling
encased in a shortcrust shell, sealed
with traditional pleated crimps.
How many pleats are you doing?
I don't know. As many as I can.
OK. Should there be a set...? There
is a set number, yeah. Is there
really? Yeah.
I'm not going to tell you now.
It's down to the bakers how many
crimps they use to seal their
pasties.
Apparently, the perfect Cornish
pastry's got 20 crimps.
We don't want none of that on it,
really.
It's just typically samosa style.
My technique is press the pastry
over itself using your fingers,
and hope it looks like a crimp.
Yeah, it's a bit messy.
This is now melting because it's
been out of the freezer too long.
That's the last one.
I'm just giving it an eggwash. It
gives a really nice sort of glaze
and shine on the pasties.
I like to imagine that when Paul has
a bath, he has a bath of eggwash.
That's how he gets that nice bronze
look.
I am adding on some wee scales quite
slapdash.
I know that they're supposed to be
really nicely neat, but I'd
rather they were cooked.
Right, going in.
I'm going to put them in for 35
minutes and check them.
How long do we have left?
Bakers, you've got minutes left.
Don't make a bet.
I won't have time for highly
decorated.
This is for the chillies on the top.
Don't have time so they're going to
go in as they are.
I was going to put a little... Karma
sign on them... yeah, but I can just
get the seeds on.
At least get some in the oven, you
know?
Let's not have that speak. No,
that's true. You're going to get
them all out.
Do you know why? Because you're
Linda -
the inventor of the karma pasty.
What will be, will be on that lot.
I'm going to give them 20 minutes at
200 and then I'll reduce the
temperature.
Let's hope they cook.
Bakers, you've got 15 minutes.
Well, 15 minutes left and I need
another 20 minutes, so...
..that doesn't really add up, does
it?
It is cooked inside, but you also
need the nice brown colour.
Oh, God. I'm going to need a
miracle.
I just put another eggwash on
because they aren't very golden.
I don't know whether to turn them
off, or if that's a bad idea.
I've got it on 250!
It's like a pizza oven in there.
How's it going? All right. Any
leakage? Yeah, all the leakage.
The butter is literally melting out
and they're not crimped
properly. Good sign? No, not great.
This is a Thai sweet chilli dipping
sauce.
Bring that to a boil, come on.
Still a little bit pale. I want them
to be a bit darker.
Bakers, you have five minutes left!
All right. I'm coming out.
I think these bad boys are done.
Crispy underneath. They look like
fish and they're pasties.
I'm going to swap them around.
Oh, God.
Bakers, you have one minute.
OK, I'm coming out.
Please tell me when there's 30
seconds.
I'll take them out at the very last
second.
My cousin made these toads for
toad-in-the-hole.
Right, here we come.
Ugh. Bakers, your time is up.
Stop what you're doing, place your
pasties at the end of your work
stations.
Ooh!
Rustic is good for pasties, right?
That's as fine as you can be with a
pasty.
I'm thinking it's a shame there's
no crimp.
The bakers' signature pasties are
about to face
Pastry Week's first judging.
Hey, Prue, Paul. Hello, Marc.
Hey, Marc. Hello.
You have the weight of the whole
of Cornwall on your shoulders.
I certainly have,
which is making me a bit nervous.
You are lacking
on the number of pleats.
How many should there be?
I think it's 20 or 21.
I was getting close.
I think you are about seven or
eight short. Yeah. Yeah.
The biggest one for me is the
colour, cos they look a bit pale.
Especially this one here,
you haven't brushed it properly.
Flavour is good, but it's bone dry.
You had cream in that as well. Yeah.
Probably a little bit more cream.
That would have really given you
more moisture in the mouthful.
It is a little bit too dry for me.
OK. Lovely pastry.
I think if you'd done it faster
and hotter,
you might have kept
a little more of the colour.
OK.
The overall look of this one is
fantastic. It is like a flatfish.
It looks great.
I was a bit worried it would be
stodgy,
but, in fact, it's certainly not.
If anything, it's a bit dry.
There's a nice kick
of flavour there,
but, unfortunately, you've got rice
sitting on a pastry,
which is very good,
but, essentially, quite dry.
I think they are a little bit messy.
You've lost the definition
in the pleats across the top.
But I like the colour of them.
I think it's very witty.
Very flaky, which is good.
Nice.
They taste amazing.
The mash works really well.
Do you remember I said
it won't work?
I was wrong.
It is very, very good.
It doesn't look good,
but the textures,
the flavours are all spot on.
They taste amazing.
Yeah, can you book me one for lunch?
Yeah, I'll book you one, no worries.
I'm serious. Yeah, yeah.
I want one. That one. Yeah.
They are very nice indeed.
They're nicely glazed,
they are well baked,
they are the right colour
and there are the little chillies
on top. Yes.
They are very impressive. Thank you.
I think your flavour is OK.
I think it's a little bit dry,
though,
I think you put too much rice in
there. OK.
Because the rice is going to dry
everything out, soak everything in.
You have lost the flavour
of the chicken, but, otherwise,
I mean, the pastry is good.
It's all right to eat, it just
doesn't, you know, wow me.
OK, that's fair enough. Can I just
taste it with your sauce? Yes, yes.
Do you know, that would have
made a huge difference?
Because it has that sweetness and
the chilli and a little bit of kick.
Thank you.
Do you know, that is really what
a pasty should look like.
It is full, the pastry looks
beautiful, soft and tender,
but firm enough to, if not hurl
over a hedge,
at least hold in your hand.
It tastes beautiful.
The spices in there, the chilli
in there was just the right amount.
It's got a nice kick of heat in
there. The textures are spot on.
It's gorgeous. Very good.
Heaven. You do realise
a handshake from me is valueless?
It's a lot of value to me. Yeah.
There you are, Mark. Phew!
It was all right. You were a bit
worried, weren't you? I was.
Well done.
Another couple of minutes, perhaps,
in the oven? I was running behind.
So you were rushing...? Yeah.
Nice and full. That's beautiful.
The lamb is cooked beautifully.
Thank you. The flavours,
the spices...
Just the right amount of veg to
meat.
It's beautiful.
That is a lovely pasty.
Because you've got a good pastry
on the outside, quite buttery.
It's really delicious. Thank you.
Thank you very much indeed.
Well done, Hermine. Thank you.
Sorry they didn't like it.
Well, you did read the stuff about
we were going to want them crimped?
Oh. Did you miss that?
I missed that on the brief. Sorry.
OK, so we have a samosa,
essentially. Yes.
I'd like the colour of them...
They are a little bit white
in places and broken up slightly,
a bit longer in the oven, perhaps?
Yes, absolutely.
Your stencilling didn't work. No.
You know what? It looks very nice.
The flavours are fantastic.
I think you've got the idea
of the samosa right in there.
I'd like to have seen the crimping
which you didn't do,
but what I do like is
the combination of the butteriness
with the samosa filling.
A delicious lunch.
Well done. Thank you.
Nice colour. You've got a beautiful
sort of golden brown colour.
You have got a little
bit of crimping on the edge.
A little bit irregular in size.
I like the fact
they're nice and fat.
There is going to be a good lot of
filling in there. Nice flaky pastry.
The filling in there, as well,
going right to the sides.
Heaven. I love that.
It's flaky,
the pastry is holding together,
its moist in the middle but not wet.
I could gobble it up.
Thank you. I think you've got the
perfect blend there of ingredients.
The texture and flavour are spot on.
Oh, thank you. Well done. Well done.
Thank you. Thanks.
Well done, Laura. I'll take that.
Oh, my God, that was amazing.
To impress Paul with the pastry
and Prue with the filling,
like, double whammy.
They liked it. What more?
I knew the flavours were going to be
good. I could smell them.
I am worried about the Technical
because, with pastry,
they can do literally anything.
If I could just not be
bottom in Technical again,
that would be great.
As usual, the bakers can
practise their signatures.
But what they will bake in
the Technical
is only now about to be revealed.
Bakers, it's now time
for your Technical Challenge,
which, today, has been set by Prue.
Prue, thanks for joining us in
the tent.
Do you have any words of advice?
This is all about refinement,
so the inside must be as perfect
as the outside.
As ever, this technical
challenge will be judged blind,
so could you two please
leave the tent?
We will see you later on.
Prue would like you to make
three raspberry
and three salted caramel eclairs.
Prue is looking for precision,
perfect piping,
baked until golden brown.
You have two hours and 15 minutes.
On your marks... Get set. Bake.
There is a lot of steps in this
recipe.
I just grabbed out all
the saucepans.
I've not made eclairs before.
I have made choux before,
but not eclairs.
Eclairs themselves will be easy,
but it's not just eclairs,
there's a lot going on.
I'm not sure about this one.
Prue, eclairs is
the Technical Challenge.
Personally, I think it's a good one.
Most people think eclairs
are very easy.
But if you want really high-end,
elegant, special ones,
then you have to do a lot of work.
There is one choux pastry
for all of these.
Well, I should think
they've all made choux pastry,
they should all be able
to make it well.
Then you have to make creme pat
to fill them all with.
Half of that creme pat needs
to be flavoured with salted caramel,
and the other half,
seedless raspberry puree.
The little kick from the salted
caramel blended with the sweetness
of the raspberry, you've got
a nice balance between the two.
You have set them a very
difficult Technical Challenge.
We are halfway through.
The bakers that are left
are really good.
You can talk, I'm eating, go on...
So it says... Make the choux.
So just make the choux.
Put the sugar, the milk,
the water and the butter into a pan
and heat it over a low heat.
Chuck the flour in.
Mix, mix, mix, mix, mix,
so it forms a paste.
It's just not thick enough.
It's just not
what I expected at all.
Oh, it's a long time
since I made it,
so I'm not 100% sure about this.
Do all right on the eclairs.
I'm all right on eclairs,
but there's so many steps in this.
It's a lot of reading, that,
isn't it? She writes books.
There's quite a racy scene
between two farm hands there.
Yes, bit by bit
until you get the right consistency.
I think it's meant to,
like, stick to the spoon,
like, not want to come off from it
very well.
It has to be dropping consistency.
You are looking for a V-shape
off a spatula or spoon.
Reluctant to drop. That's what you
want. There you go, there is your V.
I'm going to pipe the choux out onto
the baking tray.
I need to pipe carefully.
I'm happy with them.
Yeah, they'll do, they'll do.
These are going in the oven.
It does not give us any instructions
on how long to bake these for.
I'm going to start off with 15,
see how they're going,
and then just take it from there.
No, I'm not certain that's right.
I'm not certain that's right at all.
I'm making my creme pat.
Creme patissiere is just custard.
It's just a posh word for custard.
Don't want it to be lumpy,
so I'll make sure that I keep
stirring it whilst it's heating up.
Absolutely no idea what I'm doing.
Just finding new ways to make
scrambled egg.
It's a bit grainier
than I'd like it to be.
It's too wet. There's too many
elements that can go wrong on this.
Are you left-handed?
I am left-handed.
You know a left-handed person has
never won the Bake Off.
Good boost of confidence.
You know someone who has ever worn
a yellow T-shirt
has never won the Bake Off.
Oh, no!
They are not rising at all.
I would have expected to see
some movement in it.
They are looking a bit oily.
I think they are cooked, you know.
Oh, dear, they have, like, risen
quite a lot, haven't they?
They are looking nice
and crisp on the outside.
They could be slightly fatter.
I don't know how I'm going
to fill them.
They're not lovely golden brown.
They'll have to do.
They've kind of already deflated
a little bit.
No, that's not happening.
Right, let's have another think.
Bakers, you have roughly one hour,
seven minutes and 30 seconds left.
You are halfway through. You can put
it like that if you want.
I'm going to do the choux again.
Hopefully, I've got time to bake it.
Make the caramel
with 100g of sugar.
In we go.
Every time I make caramel in this
tent, it goes wrong.
I'm going to keep it on a low heat
and then I'm just not going
to touch it ever.
Got to keep my eye on that caramel.
This is taking forever.
Doesn't look right, does it?
Is it harder to cook on television?
Yeah.
Would you go on any other shows?
Would you go on Naked Attraction?
I wouldn't go on
Naked Attraction
because my body is my own business.
I'm really not sure what to do
if that doesn't work.
I'm just going to try and give her
the elements as much as I can.
I'm going to mash them up a bit.
Make a seedless raspberry puree.
I'm leaving the seeds in there
and once it's pureed down,
I'll sieve it,
get rid of the seeds.
Just a little bit thin.
I don't know if that will set.
So now,
I'm making the salted caramel sauce.
This is going to be mixed
with the creme pat
to make a nice salted
caramel custard.
It says one teaspoon of salt.
It's quite dark.
But I just need to get it
chilled now
so I can fold it into the creme pat.
I'm just really baffled.
Mine don't look like they're going
to do anything different.
I don't know why I'm making all
the additional bits
if I've got nothing
to put them in.
Do you want me to...
..go to the supermarket
and buy some eclairs?
I think you'd better.
Just split my creme pat into two
and now I'm folding it through
the raspberry
and the salted caramel.
I think I am kind of feeling in my
comfort zone right now. It's good.
It looks beautiful indeed.
Yeah, it's a little bit lumpy.
I think it'll be OK.
I know I'm going to be
really out of time,
but I'm going to have one more go.
I'm going to re-make the choux.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Now what? Fill three of the eclairs
with raspberry filling.
I'm doing this so cack-handedly.
I thought, rather than doing creme
patissiere,
I'll make a raspberry yoghurt to go
inside. So here it goes.
It's just all totally dripping out
of it.
I'm not really sure why that's
happened.
I just think my puree wasn't
thick enough
when I added it to the creme pat.
The choux are collapsed,
so it's really difficult to
get the stuff in.
We'll just have to go with it,
I think, today.
It tastes all right. It looks split,
though.
Oh, my God!
The creme pat is too wet.
Terrible. My creme pat is just flat.
The salted caramel icing is going to
be piped over the top.
That's not my finest work.
Ooh!
Nearly didn't have those, then.
Third time lucky.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
Crikey!
I'm really not sure what to
do with them.
Winging it!
This is not my usual
highly decorated standard.
Yes, there's a lot going on at once.
Just going to...
I'm so stressed.
They can have a dip of the
creme patissiere and the coulis.
You know? I've done what I can.
This is horrendous!
Bakers, your time is up.
Disappointed.
Please, bring your eclairs down
to the front and place them
behind your photographs.
Look at this, at least it gets mine
out of the way first. Well done.
Prue and Paul are looking for six
elegant eclairs.
Three filled with a salted caramel
creme pat
and three with
a raspberry creme pat.
OK, shall we start with this one?
The toppings are sort of there
or thereabouts.
And they are more or less the right
colour.
Yeah. OK, let's see what the creme
pat's like.
Oh, this one is empty.
And that one is runny.
It's completely liquid.
Mm. Nice flavour.
The flavours are right,
but it's too thick and the
consistency on the eclair
and the creme pat is not right.
Moving on to number two.
These look quite neat.
All the same size.
This icing has set all right.
Look at that. It's split.
The raspberry flavour is there, but
the consistency is all wrong inside.
What? Those weren't finished.
Oh, it's a dip one. Oh, I see.
I get it. I see.
There is no rise in that.
It obviously hasn't got any flour
in it.
I can't understand that.
That's terrible.
All right. Moving on.
These are rather fat.
But having said that,
they look like eclairs.
The raspberry one actually tastes
OK. And the eclair is baked well.
Yes, not bad effort.
Moving on. A bit skinny. Yeah.
I mean, they look neat enough.
The pastry is just not baked enough.
The flavours of both are OK.
It's the textures that are wrong.
This is an original take
on the icing.
Looks like a giant caterpillar.
Needed longer in the oven.
There's a lot wrong
with this eclair.
The creme pat is scrambled,
the pastry is really soft
and under baked.
OK, I'm cheering up a little here
because these are more or less OK.
That's empty. That's empty.
This one's got some...
The caramel in there is OK.
Oh, it is, but there's very little
creme pat in the middle.
There's nothing in there.
Moving on to the last one. Now,
these are all the same. Quite neat.
The right consistency
with the creme pat.
Good flavour as well.
Mm. Not bad at all. No. Very good.
The judges will now rank
the eclairs from worst to best.
In eighth spot, comes as no
surprise, this one, whose is this?
Linda?
A few issues with the choux,
your caramel should go on the top
and there's no creme pat inside.
In seventh place, we have this one.
Mine. They're a bit long and thin
and a bit under-baked. Yeah.
Laura takes sixth. Dave is fifth.
And Lottie gets fourth.
In third place,
we had this one. Mark.
You were redeemed by the fact
that the pastry was well-cooked
and that they tasted delicious,
but they were really messy.
In second spot, we have this one.
These are pretty good. They could
just have been a little bit thinner.
They're just a little bit too fat.
Which means, the winner
is this one.
Peter, they were delicious.
My only quarrel was
they were probably a little bit fat,
but I thought they were lovely.
We both thought they were lovely.
Well done.
That is the first time
I've won the Technical,
so tick it off the bucket list,
the Bake Off bucket list.
Really happy. Earned it well.
It wasn't my finest hour, that one.
Two hours trying to make choux
pastry, disgusting.
But tomorrow is another day.
There's just one challenge left
before Paul and Prue
decide who will be Star Baker
and who will be leaving
the tent today.
Bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's time
for your Showstopper challenge.
Paul and Prue
would like you each to make
a caged tart.
An exquisite, sweet tart
contained within
an intricately-latticed pastry cage.
You can work with any type of pastry
you like,
but it must be self-supporting
and highly decorative.
And remember,
this is your Showstopper,
so it needs to look
and taste superb!
Matthew, did you know the caged tart
was actually invented
by actor Nicolas Cage?
Yes, Noel. I did know that.
Did you know that Nicolas Cage
is a big fan of this show? Really?
Yes, he watches this and
Homes Under The Hammer.
You have three hours, 45 minutes
to complete your caged tarts.
On your marks... Get set...
Bake!
The sun is shining, yeah.
And I'm smiling.
I am at the moment.
Till we're dishing up.
This is a really tough challenge.
You know, anyone can bake a tart,
but making a caged tart...
The biggest issue is the cage,
no doubt.
I've never managed to make this
caged tart in its entirety.
Why would you make a caged tart?
It's bonkers.
It looks beautiful.
You're supposed
to showcase it, not cage it.
We've gone all out here.
We want the most
elegant latticed cage
made of pastry.
The cage can't be too solid
that you can't see the tart
and it's gotta be structurally
sound,
so it's actually
quite a difficult challenge.
This has to be
a really special tart.
It has to be luscious.
The kind of tart that you really
want to eat a huge amount of,
but you shouldn't,
because it's very rich.
What I'm looking for is a very thin,
crispy base.
Lots of filling,
punching with flavour
and a beautifully-decorated top.
They're good bakers.
I have every confidence.
First hour really is all about me
getting my doughs ready.
The bakers are free to use
whatever pastry they choose...
I'm making a sweet pastry
for the tart itself
and then I'm doing a different
pastry for the cage.
..but must keep in mind each dough
has a different job to do.
This is the sweet crust pastry
for the tart case.
The tart must be crisp
and delicious...
I'm just making
my hazelnut pastry now.
..while the cage must be strong
and sturdy.
I'm gonna have to say
it's a French sweet pastry,
because I can't pronounce...
This is my pate sucree tart base.
It's a crumbly pastry,
but it's not so crumbly that
I can't work with it.
I'm making three different types
of pastry.
It is, after all, Pastry Week.
Lottie's bake will be housed in an
ambitious choux pastry pyramid cage.
Unusually for a tart,
it will have pastry layers with
pureed, caramelised and raw apple
sandwiched in between.
I question whether
it would be a tart without sides.
I did look up the definition
of the word tart.
It's from an old French word
that means flat pastry.
Right.
Are you confident?
I'm confident in all but the cage.
But there's more than one pyramid
under construction today.
The cage is inspired by the Louvre.
I don't know if it's Showstopper
incredible,
but we'll wait and see.
Dave's aiming to serve
a set mango and lime filling,
on a cocoa and sweet pastry base,
presented in
a Parisian museum-inspired cage.
Interesting flavours.
I like the idea of mango and lime.
You're gonna stick it together
with caramel?
Yeah, it's stuck together with
caramel. That's very difficult.
Very difficult to glue it together
with caramel. Well, good luck.
This is my tart case.
I'm just trying to
not overstretch it.
I'm pricking the base of the tart.
Erm...
That's gonna allow any steam
to escape
and stop it from getting all bumpy
and uneven,
and then this pastry's gonna
blind bake. In it goes.
That's going in.
That's going in now, this one.
This is the cage pastry.
Can I just say, I love it
when you beat the butter up.
Are you thinking it's Paul?
I couldn't possibly say.
Hi, Laura. Hello!
Laura, tell us all about
your caged tart.
I'm doing a Key lime pie
inspired tart. Ooh!
I'm going with
a bit of a botanical theme,
so I'll hopefully show you I can do
delicate and fine today.
Laura's limey filling will sit
on a crunchy ginger pastry,
accented with Italian meringue.
It'll be caged in a domed puff
pastry lattice,
adorned with pastry snails
and elegant butterflies.
This one's for my dad.
He absolutely loves this.
He devours it every time I make it
for family gatherings.
Key lime pie's one of my favourite
things. Is it? I love it.
You know, you're on a winner there.
Now, I'm gonna make the pastry
for my cage.
I certainly did not make a pastry
cage before this challenge.
A true test of pastry prowess,
the bakers must hit the sweet spot
with dough strong enough not
to collapse,
but tender enough for eating.
I'm literally doing the exact same
again.
My cage sable. Pate sable.
Yeah, cocoa pate sable.
This choux isn't very robust.
Yeah, it's a hell of a risk.
I've gone for that, because if I can
nail it, it looks good.
It's the same pastry recipe
as the pastry case.
I've adapted the recipe so that it
doesn't fall apart
when it's moulded.
Rough puff isn't probably something
you would use to build a cage in.
It's quite a risky one.
I just really hope it works.
What's the cage about?
The cage is weird.
I'd never seen a caged tart before.
I don't know if I have.
No, but they do look quite cool
when they turn out well.
I'll take your word for it.
Peter's tart will have a hazelnut
pastry base,
a baked lemon filling
and blackberry curd
and it will shelter under
a domed shortcrust cage,
decorated with edible flowers.
I love a lemon tart.
It's... I think it's my favourite.
I like this one a lot.
But he's not the only baker tweaking
the classic tarte au citron.
I'm making a lemon tart,
so hopefully I will manage that.
Hermine's tangy lemon
and lime filling
will be topped with
sweet Italian meringue.
She'll box her bake in with
an ornate pastry cage.
You had such a great day yesterday.
Can you do it again?
I am hoping, cos I kept saying,
"Bread Week wasn't mine.
"Biscuit Week wasn't mine."
And I feel Pastry Week is the area
where I excel.
Good. More of the same, please.
I'm gonna start making the panels
to make the cage.
These are my stencils that I'm gonna
pipe my choux onto
and then cook it
and then assemble it.
Sounds easy, doesn't it?
No.
I've rolled out my rough puff
and I'm just using
some circle cutters
and then I'll pull that
over the mould.
This is just a lattice cutter.
It cuts out all the lattices
for you.
These are my strands
to make the cage.
Put them in the oven
and then they come off the bowl.
That's the plan.
There's no particular pattern that
I'm going for here.
It's just kind of make some nice,
wavy lines, hope it looks good
and make sure that enough
of them cross over,
so it gives it a bit of structure.
When it goes in the oven,
hopefully it will gel together.
I'm cutting out rhomboid shapes
in it now, inspired by the Louvre.
It is a pyramid. This is me
trying to be creative, all right?
Is that a cage or is that a helmet?
Who in this room would you put in
your cage, if you could?
Oh, I think, like, a really little
mini Peter would be quite cute.
Yeah.
Oi, Peter!
Laura wants to put you in a cage.
Poor kid. He looks terrified.
What would you do with him if he
was in a cage? Feed him cheese.
Noel, after this time call,
would you like to play table tennis?
Yeah!
Bakers, you're halfway through.
Hm, halfway to paradise.
I'm gonna get my tart case out now.
Ooh.
Naughty.
Yeah, I'm happy with the way
they look.
It's cracked a little bit,
but it's gonna have a filling in it,
so that'll be hidden. A little bit
darker than I wanted in parts,
but I'll be trimming all that off.
It's fine, but it's not phenomenal.
With their cages moulded,
cut out or piped,
it's now the bakers can get them in
the oven.
I'll give it 25 minutes,
then check it.
This is going in for 20 minutes.
Two at a time.
Fingers crossed.
Good luck,
my beautiful little helmet!
Please! Pray that this works.
Fingers crossed.
How's it going?
It's going all right.
It's a tough one, this one. Why?
It's just a lot to do.
A lot to think about.
A lot can go wrong.
What has gone wrong so far?
Nothing's gone wrong so far.
Well, then, you just lied to me.
All being well, Mark will put
together a pear and sage tart
with layers of pear jam,
a pear and sage mousse
that will sit inside
a rough puff pastry bottle cage,
resting on shortbread biscuit sand.
Goodness, this is an ambitious
business.
I love the idea of the sage.
I'm confident that it's gonna work.
I have to be positive.
Thank you, Mark. Fingers crossed.
Thank you very much. You've got
them excited about the flavours.
It just has to look good now as
well. It will. Good luck. Thank you.
OK, what now?
While the pastry cage
demonstrates design,
the filling for their tart is
a chance for the bakers to showcase
a flair for flavour.
This is the chocolate cremeux.
It's just like a really thick
chocolate cream.
It's toffee popcorn creme diplomate.
It tastes like popcorn at a push.
Yesterday was yesterday and
yesterday was a different creme pat.
I'm just making the gypsy tart.
It's actually just sugar
and evaporated milk.
It's been a favourite of mine
when I was at school.
That's why I'm making it.
Linda's gypsy tart has a sweet
pastry base,
topped with a coffee and
brandy-soaked sponge.
It will nestle in a colourful
rosewater-flavoured pastry dome.
Word on the street is you're doing
a gypsy tart.
I'm doing a gypsy tart, yes. What?
Cos when I was at primary
school, we used to have gypsy tart
and it was my favourite... Yeah.
..and I've never seen it since. Yeah.
And you're making it today? Yeah.
I mean, very simple ingredients.
Come on.
I don't care how simple it is.
Come on! Come on, yes.
Come on! Good luck. Thank you.
After a tough time in the technical,
Marc's also banking
on a much-loved bake.
My favourite pudding in the whole
wide world
is a blackberry and apple pie.
So, this is kind of like a posh
apple and blackberry pie.
Marc's upmarket tart will have
a sable Breton base,
blackberry jam, caramelised apples
and a chocolate cremeux.
His full puff pastry cage will be
decorated with shortcrust flowers
and vine leaves.
If it turns out how I want it,
I'll be really pleased.
I am sweating today.
There's just a lot to do. I feel...
I'm feeling behind already.
How long do we have left?
Bakers... You have one hour left.
I thought we were good in that.
Yeah, I think it worked very well.
I'm gonna get my cage out now.
It is very fragile.
It's a nice golden-brown colour.
All going well.
Looks quite good.
I was hoping they'd glue together
a bit more.
Let these cool down,
cos they're too delicate
at the moment.
I'm gonna shove it straight
in the freezer
to try and cool it down.
As cages cool,
the blind-baked tarts can be moved
on to the next stage.
Put it in the oven for 15 minutes.
Then we'll have a lemon tart.
While some fillings are baked,
others must be cooled to firm up.
I'm putting the jam in and
then build up the cremeux from that
and chill for 15 minutes.
With tarts left to set,
the bakers can crack on,
preparing finishing touches.
At last, some pear action, hey?
I'm using conference pears.
You need to stop making me say that
word in my accent.
Pear.
I'm gonna put my macaroons in.
This is a little lacy template
that I'm gonna slide onto the top
of the tart.
You know like you get a doily
and it's all da-de-da!
This is my caramel and then
we're gonna add the apples.
And that'll be one of my layers.
Let's just hope that works.
Look at this little fruit selection.
A cute lunch for a rabbit.
# I'm preparing lunch for
a rabbit. #
You look quite calm today.
# Star Baker is looming in
the distance. #
And you're making lunch
for a rabbit.
Come on, man.
Hello, lattice head.
Are you ready for a time call?
Yeah.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
What? Is that real? Half an hour?
It's gonna be tight.
Is this is the lockdown look?
That's right, kids.
If you can't get out there
on the high street,
then pastry is your answer.
Yeah, it's done.
Oh, look at that, though. Yeah.
It's a good set.
Wonderful.
Very happy.
This is the cage.
Oh, God. This is terrifying.
The cage is pretty delicate,
so it's all about getting it off.
This is what this entire bake
hinges on right now.
It's a little scary.
Oh, I'm panicking now. I'm rushing.
If it works, I'm laughing.
This is the tricky bit,
cos I need to glue all the sides.
I would say they're brittle.
Oh!
Let's see if this comes off,
shall we?
I've never felt so stressed.
This is isomalt.
It's like sugar,
but more predictable.
Glue the hell out of that lot.
I'm trying to stay nice and calm.
I don't know what to do.
It's just breaking
as I'm trying to get it off.
I don't think I'm going to get it
off in one piece.
It will look messy.
Is that stuck?
Damn it.
Oh, I'm so pleased.
Oh! Oh!
Eurgh!
It's still too hot.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
This is now assembly, yeah.
Here we go.
It's gonna be like a flower piece on
the top of the tart.
That is the Italian meringue.
The meringue's gonna go around
the outside of the tart.
Then the fruits just sit
pretty in the middle.
This is my blackberry curd on top.
Tastes good. Perfect.
It's just a case of laying
the apples on,
arranging the blackberries
and then run.
This is not the way I want to finish
this off,
but it's gonna have to do.
Not quite what it should be.
It might be a bit sticky.
I'm happy with the tart.
Hopefully I can cage it.
Just feel the tension in the room!
It's broken now.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
I don't know what to do.
It just all collapsed.
I'll see if I can get it off.
I've got about five seconds.
Eurgh!
OK, bakers. Your time is up.
I just wanted to get a little bit of
colour on it.
It better taste good.
I will take that.
Oh, that was touch and go,
I'll be honest.
I don't think I've been as proud of
anything in my entire life
as I am of that.
It's judgment time for the
bakers' cage tart Showstoppers.
Dave, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper, please?
I think it looks great.
I do like the look you've managed
to achieve with the mango.
I think it's wonderful.
All it has to do now is taste great.
Fingers crossed.
It's nice and neat.
The flavour is absolutely lovely.
Love the mango.
The base is just about
the right thickness.
It marries up beautifully
with the mango.
I think you've done a great job,
because you've given an impact
to the top of the tart, as well.
The overall look is so harmonious.
Very good job. Well done.
Cheers, thank you. Really good.
It looks highly effective.
The colour looks very, very good.
I like the way the tart looks.
Yeah. Looks great.
Lovely and rich, the chocolate.
I do have a problem with the base.
It's a bit big for the chocolate.
Yeah.
But I think your decoration
is very beautiful.
I'd liked to have seen
this chocolate
to the edge of
a very rich chocolate pastry
which was really thin.
That would've been spot-on. OK.
Cos that base looks awkward. Yeah.
So it doesn't belong... Yeah.
..with that delicate chocolate
in the middle. OK, sure.
I think it looks beautiful.
I think it's a really clever design,
and I think you've managed
to get it to work...
..until Paul Hollywood wrecked it.
Thunder fingers.
However, that shows that
the pastry will be delicious.
The flavour's lovely.
Mm. But you could have gone a little
bit thinner with that base. OK.
But I have to say,
the pastry is beautiful.
It is, really good.
However, this is a really
big, hefty,
Paul Hollywood...
..cage, with a delicate,
tiny, feminine middle.
It's a Prue Leith tart...
And a Paul Hollywood cage.
..with a Paul Hollywood base.
Overall, though, I think all your
flavours are absolutely spot-on.
I'm very impressed with your cage.
Thank you. I think it looks lovely.
I think it's highly impressive.
The tart underneath looks
very, very nice.
Mm.
I love...
..the Key lime flavour.
The lime, you can feel it
at the back of your...
Mm... cheeks. It's like, oof.
And I like that from lime.
That's how a lime should taste.
You know, give you a nice kick.
I think your decoration's beautiful.
Overall, I think your taste's
amazing, looks good.
Excellent.
I think you've excelled yourself.
Mm.
You really have.
Wow, thank you. That means
a lot to me. Thank you.
What happened to the cage?
It usually lifts up, but today
it stayed on the bowl.
Yeah, I love the gypsy colours.
That's right, yeah. Are great.
OK, let's taste it.
Mm.
I love the flavour.
It's a bit thick,
that gypsy tart, actually.
It could have been
a little bit thinner.
Um... I quite like the flavour,
it's very traditional.
It's quite frustrating that
you don't see the full impact.
The way it looks doesn't look good.
Well, I have to say,
your cage is sensational.
Really beautiful.
The artistry in there
is exceptional.
The tart itself...
..I question whether it would be
a tart without sides.
Very squidgy.
Very.
Mm.
That tastes absolutely beautiful.
But it does look a right mess.
All the independent flavours
are very, very good.
All the textures are good.
What you've made is very good,
but "Is it the brief?"
is my question.
I like the rather random way
you've done the cage.
I think it's really beautiful.
It's quite solid, it almost looks
like it's made of bread.
I'm just happy it's held up.
Lovely and tart.
Mm. Mm.
That's delicious. Puts a smile on
your face, doesn't it? Very nice.
I think partly because the back
of your cheeks are going...
..and so it sort of forces a smile.
It's called a happy tart, that one.
That's lovely.
So, the cage didn't work.
It's not a good one.
Not compared with what
you were achieving recently.
That's not... Yeah.
..Mark. Mm.
Your piping's all irregular,
as well.
The poached pears
don't look appetising.
It's delicious. It's unusual,
but I really like it.
The pastry's far too thick.
I think you missed something
on this one. Mm.
At a core level, not just at the
fact that you never got a chance
to finish it with a cage.
Didn't go well, did it?
I'm obviously in a very
precarious position now.
Pastry Week!
It was supposed to be my week.
Hey-ho. Fair comments.
I think that's probably the nicest
bit of feedback that I've got,
that line of it being a happy tart.
Paul said my pastry was amazing.
"Amazing."
I mean, what more...
That's definitely the best
feedback that I've had yet.
I got a bit choked, actually.
I've... I'm absolutely made up.
I thought they did quite well
after the eclairs.
The cages were astonishing,
except for Mark L.
And Linda's. And Linda's.
I think,
in spite of her exploding cage,
Hermine must be in line
for Star Baker.
I thought the flavours of her lemon
tarte au citron was fantastic.
You did quite like Dave's.
I thought his cage was incredible.
What about Peter?
Cos you liked his, as well.
I did like his.
And he came first in Technical.
Is he not in line for Star Baker?
He struggled in his Signature
quite badly. Right.
But I think Laura's Showstopper
was amazing.
Laura's had a good week, hasn't she?
She's really come up.
So, who is in danger of going home?
Mark L. His cage fell apart.
He could be in a little bit
of trouble. And Marc E.
He struggled in the Technical
and he struggled in the Signature.
I think Linda's in trouble.
She struggled across
the first two challenges.
She didn't finish her cage.
Close, then. It is.
It's painfully close.
Well done, bakers.
You must be exhausted.
I'm sure you want to know
who Star Baker is,
so I'll tell you.
Star Baker this week is...
..Laura.
Well done!
Congratulations, Laura. Bloody hell.
That leaves me with the rotten job
of announcing the person
that is leaving us this week.
It does get harder every week,
cos there's less of you
and we get to know you more.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
..Linda. I'm sorry.
No, that's good.
I can't really be sad.
I've been like a child
at Disneyland, really.
Well done, you. I'm so sorry.
It's been amazing.
One of the highlights of my life.
How dare they! Thank you so much.
You've been brilliant.
She is a very good baker,
but she had a terrible week.
I know I can bake.
I just haven't done enough.
I am so proud of myself, yeah.
I am.
Well done, Laura. Oh, thank you.
You did well there. Thank you.
I'm still a bit in shock.
I think I'm a bit, like,
did that actually just happen?
When it came to the Showstopper,
I thought Laura
smashed it out the park.
A well-deserved Star Baker.
I'm just gonna try and get through
for as long as I can.
Hashtag winging it.
I'm looking forward to next week.
Japanese Week.
Yeah, one more.
Let's do one more week.
It's getting tougher and tougher now
and I cannot mess up
like that again.
Yeah, I'm gonna be better
next week.
Next time...
The adrenaline has kicked in.
..it's a Bake Off first,
with Japanese Week.
I just like it being a bit
different. Yeah. Cakes are boring.
Who will run out of steam
in the Signature? Whoa. Good God.
The bakers are spread thin and
turned over in a tense technical...
Flip, go on! Yes!
The winner right here.
..and a spectacularly sweet
Showstopper...
Cute ..that will leave one
of the bakers with a sour taste.
It's tearing a bit, isn't it?
Oh, God. BLEEP mess.
I don't know why you're so upset.
I think that looks pretty neat.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media